in this video we shall dive into the
world of money making
and see how much the monster movies that
we so love has made a profit off of us
on this list we will have 10 of the
biggest money making monster movies
which are live action and not animated
just to mention
shin godzilla made 153 million dollars
and cloverfield made 170 which are
dwarfs
against the others on this list even
king of the monsters and 1998 tristar
godzilla did not make it here with both
of them
crossing over 380 million so check it
out
number 10 pacific rim this movie brings
to the u.s big screen
a new term in which is kaiju actually an
old
uh word used by toho and the japanese
which means giant monsters
but in this movie kaijus from another
universe are sent to earth via an
undersea portal and the humans piloting
robot makers called jaegers are sent to
battle them to death
this movie made 411 million usd in the
box office
number 9 rampage of course what movie
list is complete without the rock
dwayne johnson stars in this giant
monster movie of 2018 called rampage
and in this flick a pathogen infects a
gorilla and a couple of other animals
and turns them into rampaging monsters
that end up fighting each other
this movie grossed over 428 million
dollars worldwide
and received mixed reviews from critics
number eight godzilla 2014 the first
monster verse movie ever
the 2014 godzilla had a very thrilling
start especially with the trailers and
all
but sadly the movie had godzilla
appearing for a total of only eight
minutes
and even though the mutos were a great
invention the movie made less than
expected
crossing over 529 million dollars but
still
the most of a godzilla film that has
ever made
number seven the meg well jason statham
was in the movie so that is why the mech
made a bit more than godzilla kotm
and released in 2018 the movie had a
budget of 178 million
and made a good profit with 530.2
million in gross revenue
this movie is about messing with the
ocean and releasing a monster
that was thought to be extinct the mech
was a giant shark about 80 feet long
with an equally big appetite number 6
king kong 2005 set in 1933
it follows the story of an ambitious
filmmaker who coerces his
a cars and hyde ship crew to travel to
the mysterious skull island
there they encounter prehistoric
creatures living on an island as well as
a legendary
giant gorilla known as kong whom they
capture and take to new york city
a remake of the original and this movie
made 562 million worldwide
number five gong skull island the giant
ape does it again
coming at the number 5 spot although
this one isn't based on the stories of
anne darrow
and the helpless lover boy kong in this
most reverse movie kong is an alpha
species that battle against skull
crawlers
and defends his home from all that he
perceives as enemies of the peace
this one made 4 million more than the
last gong entry
totaling 566 million dollars
number 4 jurassic park 2 finally we come
to the universe of the giant dinosaurs
jurassic park 2 is set for years after
the first film
and it follows a group of people
studying the behavior of dinosaurs
living free on the island only to
encounter another group capturing them
to be put in an amusement park
in san diego in the united states which
obviously is a recipe
for disaster this film made 618 million
dollars worldwide
number three jurassic park the first
movie of the franchise
and the pillar that all the other
jurassic movies were set on
this movie brought to us all the magic
of dinosaurs
and how man trying to tame nature would
only lead to destruction
initially making 912 million in the box
office
this flick is still seen today in
theaters and is the slowest ever to
climb up the ladder to becoming a
billion dollar blockbuster
number two jurassic world fallen kingdom
set three years after the destruction of
jurassic world theme park
owen grady the protagonist and claire
returns to the island of isla nubla
to save the remaining dinosaurs from a
volcano that's about to erupt
they soon encountered terrifying new
breeds of gigantic dinosaurs
and a conspiracy that threatens the
entire planet this movie made
over 1.3 billion dollars and number one
jurassic world
ever since the last jurassic park movie
was released in 2001
people all over the world were dying to
revisit their childhood awe
and relive the magic of seeing dinos on
the big screen
so preying on this weak point of all of
us jurassic world was released in 2015
and this movie is still to date the
highest grossing giant monster movie
ever
breaking records at 1.67 billion dollars
in revenue
and with this we come to the end of this
list of the 10 highest grossing giant
master movies ever
so do hit that like and subscribe button
and that notification bell too
for regular updates on new videos on
monsters guide you and weird weird
creatures
take care fam